Can't really tell mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Okay, who are we missing DK and me on?
me on
Me putting on the most try hard Perik's right now that I remember I'm letting you just say some straight. Where are you my love?
No, I
Wonder what killer
Oh
Wait, you can't see which we can't see you, but you can see us. You'll see that I'm called it and oh
My god DK is acting up. She's actually acting up
She sent me a DM saying like before the the the time slot for DVD started
She sent me a DM going how to dream you were really mad at me
And you and like you started hating me and I was like oh really and she goes you were really mad and then I was like
You're in time for DVD and she goes no you hate me
Do you do you can not do this do you can I be playing no you have to use that hard
You're asking this is the first time I've ever done. I don't even collab before so I need to be on my best behavior
I have a hundred percent talk to you at the end of the stream. I am so sorry
Now talking to you much I can only
She said no missy hate to me, but the collab is miss ma Zalee
Because she had a dream that I was
I
What I don't hate you you're in binding
Right now
Can you tell her to get in here before I actually start?
Before actually I
Wouldn't do that. No, literally last time I talked to DK. I was like I was like, I love you DK. Say back
I love you DK. Say back. Yeah, she didn't do it. That was the last of their DK
I just woke up. Oh morning
I think I think tomomi will have to fill in because
Can you hop on
Then we can just do public matches and get killed together
No, no, it's not good. Don't want me. Don't want me was locked and loaded ready. I can't believe you hate me
I
Decade the last time I spoke to you. Stop crying the last time I spoke to you
I literally went DK. I love you. Say back and I tried to make you say it back for like at least 10 minutes
I dreamt about Leon Kennedy. Yeah, I get better games elbow. So that was on you
You just called you can elbow
Elbow
They get no, okay, okay. I literally I love you. I said this oh, you're scaring the new bridge. She literally just okay
Strani literally just said that it was her first time interacting with everyone
Hi
No, it takes the final get to talk to you all. I'm sorry. I'm so copped
No, no, no, you're not we're literally stuff because the case that you're crying
And it's your first time meeting them. I thought that you would be on our best
You're
Okay, let's
Yes, we're gonna build no go ahead to be quick. I'll make everyone do their self-introduction. Don't worry about it
I'm trying to remember any pair and I have sprint burst an urban invasion. I can't remember anything else right now
That we used to be the male
Okay, let's do self-introduction. I'm gonna start off with picking out Zellie
My name is yelling. I'm a slime
She's a slime. Oh
Okay, Stroni hi, I'm Stroni cuttles. I'm from genuine veal or indulge. We're also known as the company full of slags
I love you so much
I think I think both me and Zellie did I watch the long actually
Thank mercy for that one there
It was really nice working with your company. I have to admit your manager was fantastic
Hold on
I'm trying to simultaneously clean something that I spilled. Okay, uh, don't want to clean it
Hi, I'm Tom on me. Um, sorry. My name on this girl right now is black sea color from roblox
But I'm Tom on me. Hi from then five being you. I'm a tiger
I'm going to did you say cringe?
I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. Stroni. I love you so much. And I'm so sorry. I invited these weirdos
No, we're normal. I swear. I feel like I'm in my own
No, okay, no because I I for so many okay now that I'm looking at like the roster
Now that I'm definitely not the
Okay, I am getting there now that I'm looking at the roster. It's like I might I heard about a stront
It's her first
It's her first time
It's her first time get that and then and then we got like probably
The freakiest freaks from me
The worst the worst
Uh
Your contact name and my phone is freak my freaking you were the freakiest freaker. I did not exclude myself
I did not exclude myself, but I'm just saying I'm just saying like the combination of tomomi dk and zellie
Freak nation that is freak nation. Isn't that a perfect match?
I feel like that's the perfect match I couldn't have asked for a better collab pair partners at the same time then
Really really
Are you sure? I will freak you out at any point. It's okay. I'll kick them. I don't know. I feel like it's hard to kind of be like
Oh, or maybe a bit too freaky with strony all things considered, you know
What's the water agency is known for it's like, I don't know. This might be the the the perfect match up
Yay, we're not freaks. Oh my god. Oh mommy. I don't think I have your
Team team called
Um, actually, yes, I see you on dead by daylight right now. Let me click join game and just pull up to your lobby
Why is your name that?
Oh killing you guys
Your name was blocked for me and it was just kill and then it was censored
All right
Oh god, okay, hold on
Setting things up. I totally have full
can you
I got an iPad yesterday because um my sister and I both are going to school and we only have one laptop
So I thought I'll be really nice and I'll let my little sister have the laptop
So I have an iPad now, which means I can actually be an iPad baby
It won't be an iPad. I'm very excited. Okay. Well, okay. DK just said that like
She forgot
She forgot to download uh dead by daylight
Are we get
So we're gonna play
Yeah, sorry, sorry. No, I don't know what I was gonna say. No, no, go ahead. Go ahead and stage all yours
Actually, everyone's no, I really I really didn't know what I was gonna say
I was trying to say dummy, but then I started saying dilly and then I was like, okay. Well, like the joke is over
Like it's too late now. Oh, okay
Okay, I'm inviting you guys
I'm super. Okay. I don't have anything unlocked on this account. So I'm sorry if I have dogwater perks do not judge me
Why am I Nancy? Sorry. Hold on. I just play my I spend my points. Oh my god. I have no perks either. Wait
Oh no, we're gonna get slaughtered
If we're coming in with no parents like all of us
Sure, let's radio. I'm spending my points. This is gonna take a little bit actually, okay
They are
I'll play the healer
We're playing we have to play without you so we we're playing one with a random killer. Yeah, but I said
Wait, aren't you free? No. No. Oh, they are in customs. Yeah
The other thing is I I'm gonna be honest
I don't know if we'll find a game in the regular mode because everybody's playing 2v8 right now
So we might be waiting a while to get into the game anyway. Okay. Well, it's gonna take 10 minutes
Uh for me to be done
For your information, so just play one without me. I'm so sorry. I'll come back in 10 minutes. I will disturb you guys
Oh, we already found a match. Oh, never mind
Okay, because like I tried playing a regular earlier and it I just I gave up
All right, we've got a killer. Of course you're leon
Why am I backwards? I don't know if you guys see it on you see on my
On my other account. I have I have nicolas cage
so like
Yeah, same
Zellie oh, yeah for context, uh, so I don't know. Zellie is very, uh, normal about leon
Zellie has issues. Oh, okay. You don't want to talk
Oh, yeah proof proof. Do I have issues?
Hey, that was all of us that was all four of us
Kids kids, that's it. Okay, so sorry dad
Okay, uh, so honey, I'm just letting you know right now. You have 110 percent the privilege to to bully anyone
I don't know. I don't bully. I don't
You're new here and these people are already at 110 percent in energy. So 100 bring that energy like back
Okay, like so, I'll be okay. When my girl
Don't when my girls act up, but bend them over my knee and spank them
I feel like if I like spanked zellie because she's a slave I'd get spanked back somehow
I'm gonna shut my mouth now
Whoa
Are you getting changed? I'm gonna
It's ghost face
Ghost face
Even I can get behind that
Are they definitely changed this? Oh someone's getting hunted
There's over there what on earth are all these
Perks on my screen. It's like mange broken on the side. I'm like, what do you mean? I'm just doing a generator, please
This game certainly has some upgrades over the years
At least the last time it was a bit near. Oh, I've played very eerily. I'm in trouble. Oh
I'm a be honest. I was literally playing earlier today by myself. Okay. I'm being chased so everyone can do gents because I'm
I'm going I'm getting chased. Oh, I'm on it. I'm on it. I got you. Oh, I'm in trouble
I need a palette. I don't know where palette. Oh, I'm so sorry whoever's red is with the hat
I think if you're near you may I might have just
I was by the I was by the jet
The heart I'll get in the house. It's still gone for me. Leave me alone
We're working on a Jen inside
Oh
Okay, okay, it's okay. It's fine. Yeah. No, no, no
He like stopped at a palette because he thought I was gonna lip it because he thought I was a good player
And I suck so badly that I
I'll then and I still help with the back
So be careful
Is
He's at the police car in the mid map a mid map police car
Is coming for you
Okay, he's still mid map police car mid map police car. That's the only color I've got for you
I need to make a bomb
He's still chasing me. Leave me alone. I'm just a rubbish Claudette. I'm gonna bomb this generator. I just don't know
I'm gonna bomb your house
Please don't like it
Sally trying for your birthday game
Oh the pipe bomb you promised
You reached that that special age where you get a special package here. Why do I keep hearing harpy?
I think I'm being chased, but I don't actually physically see him. No, he's uh, he's on me now
I hear so like wandering around like he didn't know what he was doing. Oh my god. Tell me we're literally so
Is the heartbeat
Why is he I think they heartbeat
Oh, he's being nice
He's being nice. He wants to be friends. Wait, actually
at the police car
Wait, is that a stream sniper? Hi. Is that one of ours?
Maybe or maybe he just wait teabag multiple times if you're the stream if you're a stream sniper
Tell me what you're doing. I got a teabag anyway. Oh, I guess it's the only way he can communicate
Hey
Okay, break the pilot if you're a stream sniper
Okay, no, it's not that fast. It's not that fast spin around 360 if you are a stream sniper
No, you might not have healing not
What why is he being nice does he want a point
Some killers just want points for doing stuff like if they have a weird totem thing on
Where can we do gents then um
We're actually so attractive the killer doesn't even want to perish us
Oh
Ghostface is my husband
Guys no, yes
Oh, wait, someone came in and I had the last word
Ha
Is it gonna start I can tell him to I can tell him to hook me. It's okay
Is it gonna start slaughtering us when we try to leave is that his and maybe he has perks for the end game?
And this is like a oh, I'm a nice killer and then as soon as you go open the gates everything is like locked off
You can't do anything
Yeah, it's a ruse. I can't believe it. It's broke. You all look like new players. Don't say such things
We'll forget we'll forget and pay because we look like baby
Oh, wait, yeah
Oh, he's coming. No, we're actually pros on our other accounts
Working guys know it. She's my wife
I'm working baby
Also miss my congrats on your donation going so well, I was I was watching some of it yesterday
And your dad came on stream, which was the cutest thing ever. Oh my god
Yeah, my dad was oh
My dad my dad was on stream
That was so cute
Then everyone doing the colons as well. I'm like, oh miss my soul. Love. That's the door. It's so nice to see
I was so like
I
Follow me bro, if they start splashing let us know because
We're done
I don't know what uh
Oh, wait, my window is open and I can smell someone's make dinner in the neighborhood
Oh my god, you guys made it just in time because my game is literally finished right now
We didn't even have to do anything the killer didn't hurt us all this round. I don't know why
It was a friendly killer. I saw that
That was funny. Well when I was miss missy, can you ask him if he knows about being you?
I will not
Oh, I'll do it in chat. I'll be the one to ask. I'll bet. Do you know what? Wait, zele, you would do it
Zele, you would do it
I love you, zele and strane said they would do it
Okay
Does he want any
Like he does he not want any point? I feel like he's one of us
There's no way that the first game we get playing a multiplayer
Can a game and he's nice. Okay. I'm gonna leave because we're about to get stabbed by the the entity but I left already
Okay, I'm out. I'm out. I'm out. I'll early set up the next game
But I don't like do I want to be the killer? I don't
I'll try
No, it's up to you. I could always be the hunter since no one's interested in killing great
Thank you for being so nice excavation mark
uh
I don't know if you were a stream sniper though
We actually
Wait, is he writing in the chat? I'm asking if I don't know if he can talk
Oh
Oh, he's it's a global. I think he's on console. So we can't talk back. We're we'll never know
I don't be a mystery. Oh, by the way, what is your what? What is your accent? I really like it. It's so cute. I'm scottish
So if you don't scottish, oh my god, I love scottish accents
If you don't understand me, please do not be afraid to ask me to repeat myself because
No, no, no, I mean honestly
Like I think I mean I I can hear the scottish accent, but it's not super strong. It's not super strong
I mean, I can put it stronger
But I don't oh, okay
I love it. Right guys. How's it going? I'm stronny calls today. We're playing dead by daylight. We're miserable
It's a uniform if you're a supporter you can find it on our channel. Just type in miss my via noon
You'll pop up. You'll also find zele. You'll also find graves. You'll also
That's how I love it
I love it so much. I love it so much
Oh, yeah, wait, sorry. Sorry. I'm like booting it up. Let's say it. I don't know why but it's
It usually takes a lot more dbd to like boot up for some weird reason. I don't know
In the meantime, can you tell me what your dream exactly was?
Oh
So it was that lead birthday
um
Yes
Uh, we were all having a sleepover and my Iggy
And then suddenly I saw something like Ike. I'm gonna write it to you
Okay
Also, by the way guys, I'm really bad at being killer, but wait, wait, I'll gonna write uh, uh, yeah write it
You
Didn't know graves had a dream that miss ma was mad at her. So we're about to get the intel. We're about to know why
Ah
Also, also there's a very random, but I saw what on my over as stranny
Would you mind if I if I drew you a a fuji at some point? Oh my god. No, I don't mind. Oh
Oh
That would be so cute. That would be very kind of you. Thank you miss. Well, you don't have to offer that though
I feel like you're so busy like literally you do you not feel busy because it's like when you do a don't
Athon like I'm so nervous for mine because it's like you promise more content than you already produced and I'm like
Oh, don't be stressed. Don't try to do a little thing. You don't have to do that
Um, but if you do it, I mean, I'm not gonna say no if you want to draw me a fuji
I'm not like I'm not a good driver
By any means but like I like I do a little doodle so fancy
I was like if you don't have one and if you don't mind me make no not at all
I think your first one. Oh, I'd love that. I'm allowed to be that annoying person
That's like, oh, I get something for free, but I'd like to make a request
Yeah, make a request, of course. Can I have my little reefling with me in the image?
I don't I don't mind wear but anywhere because I like my little reefling with me all day. Yeah
Oh, that's okay. I I finished writing it
Imagine getting a gift from the birthday girl on her birthday
Or is it just a donut on or is it your birthday? Yeah, and it's my birthday. Okay. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Yes, yes
Basically for some reason I was like upset. I don't know why like the three of us were hanging out for some reason
I was upset and then you're like, what's wrong and I'm like
Like fuck you. Yeah
Yeah, she was literally like you're such a bitch
And then Zully is like the one trying to calm me down and then that's so he's staying in growling at her like
Bro, what I just did I just like bring you my voice out you or something and you were crying
Yeah, you did
But I don't even when I when I'm mad I don't raise my voice nor did I really get mad ever
You can you never seen me mad
I can't believe you did that to her
Yeah, okay. We have known each other for a year now. You have not seen me mad a single time
No, I've seen you mad in my dream
All right, bro. All right, okay ready up
Ready when you are
I am
Oh, shit
I'm just changing perks. I don't know what the fuck to you. Don't take it that seriously because I'm
No, but I still need to pick pick like all my perks are just for running away as soon as you find me basically
I'm like right sprint first get me out of here. We're already like I'm reading. I'm just reading them through
I'm ringing silly perks. Okay. Where do we want to go guys? Which map?
I'm gonna go to your house
My house my house is not it. My house is not a map in this game
The v and u collaboration were dead by daylight. I'd buy that dlc real quick. Let's snap that up
Okay, I'm gonna send you guys to the red forest. Goodbye. Bye. Oh
Bye
meow
No, I
No, I forgot to bring the fucking flashbang. No, it's so over
DK I'm literally I'm the one that's the killer. It's so yeah, I know but I but I thought it would be funny to flashbang you
I think that it's very
You got it. Thank you. Thank you
I increased luck. He he it was someone put chess then okay
Meow meow meow
Meow meow. Oh no where you're playing as the legion, bro
Oh, you're starting to cook me already. I haven't even done anything. I literally started by going. Hey guys
I'm not that good at fucking playing this fucking game
I'm the ADK when I get you DK
What do you mean? I just don't know where you're playing as leader. That's so cool
Or in your fucking ponytail the tim I
I I I sent this to the red forest. Okay. We're in
Oh, I'm right here. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Let's work on a generator to get early on. Okay, yeah
Can you see any I don't see any I'm fucking playing leon. Oh, there there's one right here, bro. Yeah, let's go leon
All right. Thank you for supporting me leon. It's so welcome leon anything for you, bro
Well, it's going so well leon. Yeah, I think something is happening right now. I think something is happening too leon
Are you getting to it? It's so very good
These are real leons being chased right now. I'm being chased leon
Leons doing
Secret shit. Oh, I'm gonna end it. You didn't know the side quest
Yeah
What is going on why are you looking back at me like that you were looking back like you were like like
Well, I'm waiting for you to move or do something
I can't even remember what Legion does. Are you the doctor that runs like Jekyll and Hyde Legion or
I don't know. I just know the Legion is like super fast or something. That's like
Mismud do you stab me? I don't know how to use this ability. That's
Do you have like a little crowbar looking thing? I try to remember so bad like I killed leon leon. I'm hooked leon
Oh
Okay, I know the killer is
Okay, the killer is gonna know that you said that
Thank you, bro. Thank you leon. I appreciate it. It's leon. He can handle it. Why aren't you playing as Ada?
Well, because I don't know. I didn't want to be cringe and match with you guys cliff. I'm
Okay, I'm messing with you guys
Leon bro, what's your 12 leon bro. I'm gonna fucking die. Don't do that, bro. It is a batter
Why are you trying I can't I can't oh oops
Did we let the birthday girl win? Do you like the fire fight? Do you like the fireworks?
Uh, yeah, they're pretty cute
Leon I got taken again by the Legion leon. That's not very cool leon guys
It's my second hook
Leon it's my second hook. I gotta fucking die leon. I'll get you off the hook man
I'm afraid you're getting saved by Claude at the same. Sorry. I'm done when you die
I have I have super fast heels
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Hello. You were gonna camouflage. I have healed
Yeah, so many colors just like leaves. I was like, I wonder if she'll notice
Oh, sorry on my screen. I literally just grabbed you in your ass
Oh my inappropriate
Miss condom. Oh my god
I didn't mean to
I don't mean to we literally kiss off stream. So it doesn't matter leon. Where are you leon?
Wait, you kiss each other off. Wait, what?
What who?
You kiss what?
Me? Yeah
No, no, what are they?
I think I'm lost leon. Okay, just follow the sound of my voice. I'll follow your voice leon. Okay
I don't like you guys very much
Leon
why
Leo
I don't know where I am. I'm here a generator
Hey, I'm going to generator. Okay. I'm now running away from the generator. Oh my god, leon turn around
I don't know. I found you leon. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go find a generator together leon. Oh leon, wait
Something is happening leon. Hey somebody want to come on hook killing you guys. No miss ma. How did you see that?
I was lurking in the shadows
Oh, no, leons leons. Go save go save go save leons. Yeah, it's
How am I still up? I don't know how i'm still up. Wait, what what what perk is this?
How am I not down?
Uh, yeah, I wonder who I don't know what perk that is. I have bought any knowledge
Urban evasion someone's doing that to me someone must have a perk that keeps me up because you've whacked me multiple times
That's why are you are you multiple this?
Yeah, lesion applies like when they're running they apply like deep wound
So it's like that thing where you have to like amend yourself, but you're not like
I'm learning because I was like, uh, how am I getting further away from you?
I should be knocked down. I feel like this is cheating if i'm not getting knocked after the second hit
Don't worry leons. I've got this
Myself leon
Hey
I think we're gonna make it
Thank you
I'm running away leon
Do you have borrowed time leon leon run away. I do not actually but it's okay. She'll never
Oh
Right now
Oh, no, oh you took a hit for me. What the fuck is happening? Why did all three of you get wounded? I got protected
Okay, oh my god
How dare you do that to my honor leon
You will pay for this
I'm dying
No, no leon i'm just scared to rescue leon
No, forget your memories. They are fading. Yeah. Yeah, this is this is your first took right?
This is not the survivor you're looking for
This is your first took right leon
Oh, no, the red light the red light the red light. She's so cool. She's touching me. She's touching me
I will play this main game. Don't think I don't no don't break it. Don't break it. You're supposed to actually win
You're supposed to let me love you
That white woman
Ah, I'm not gonna make it. I'm not gonna make it. Okay. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I'm hiding here. Go away
Leave me alone. Bull. Leave me alone leon
We gotta work hard leon. I'm wiggling. I'm wiggle waggling
Put me down, mister
I don't know where i'm going. I'm scared. Yeah, I better follow the same
Okay, I can both smell each other
Whoa, you smell so good leon. What kind of cologne do you use?
What kind of cologne do you use leon?
Kind that's five dollars. Thank you. Oh same leon. That's crazy. That's such a coincidence leon. I know
Uh leons by any chance are you opening a door?
Yes, okay. I'm coming over leons. Please expect me
I'm coming over
Okay, okay. That's good. That's good. That's good
Killing you guy
It's okay. I'm I'm not dead yet
Where's the gun? I'm not dead yet
Leon on rescue mission
Killing you guys I can never die. I can only kill. I don't know what
Oh, yeah
Yeah
Toxic toxic toxic leon
Let's go
I'm gonna sacrifice myself for you. I'm body blocking. I'm body blocking
Oh my god, you're body blocking. I'm body blocking. I need to get the fucking
I don't think I can
Run, guy, guys
Run, run, run, run, run! Just go, just go, just go!
Oh no, oh no
I'll take you at least
Oh no
You're killing your guy
You're trying, you're trying, you're trying
Running your fools, running your fools
Wait the hatch. Did you make it?
Get the hatch, get the hatch, get the hatch
No way the hatch spawned right there
I don't know where that is.
It was all talked to the hell.
What can you speak to?
Yeah, it spawned right in front of the exit,
which was weird.
Give him ogre.
Ta-da!
That was really sweet.
Oh, no, Msma, you forgot to put Perkz on.
Oh, no.
Oh, oh, for Msma.
Oopsies.
Did you not have Perkz on that entire?
Well, we so cheated.
Sorry, you didn't have one Perkz to use against us.
Oh, really?
It's really like Msma's is empty if you tap to the next thing.
No, I feel like you could have easily killed us if you have,
like, there's something called Insta-kill or something.
I don't know.
No way.
I want to kill them every second.
I don't have any.
I play with zero Perkz.
Oh, you just that NLG, clearly.
Should we switch between killers and survivors?
Yes, please.
Yeah.
Oopsie.
Who wants to be a killer?
Zellie wants to become a killer.
Not me.
Why?
I don't want to be a killer.
I can be huntress if you guys don't want to kill each other.
I love huntress.
She's so pretty.
How do I do that?
Do you have to host it?
I think I have to host it myself.
No.
All you have to do, actually, you can switch.
There's like on the, OK, well, everybody left anyway.
Oh, well, don't play game.
Hold on.
No, it's OK.
On the side menu, there's like, it's like kind of like near the bottom.
There's like a little eyeball.
Swapy thing?
There's like a little icon that you can keep clicking to like swap
between killer, spectator, and survivor.
Well, we need to hurry it up because like the killer on my menu
is like groaning, and I don't want to hear it.
OK.
Wait, can you?
I don't mean to do that, sorry.
Oh, God, I don't know what any of the perks for the killers are gold.
Wait, am I in?
I did you get that invite, Mismar?
No, can I get an invite?
Oh, I got to add you on steam.
Wait, wait, if Mismar actually gets from there.
Yeah.
OK.
Oh, can you?
Right.
Don't judge my addition for the refunds.
I can see the POV of what I'm putting on right now.
OK.
Stop.
I'm here.
I'm putting on as well.
I'm here to win.
I'm not here to lose.
Oh, my God, it's Ada.
Hi, Ada.
I'm literally in love with you, Ada.
My name is Leon.
Hi, Leon.
My name is also Leon.
No, my name is Leon.
You even know what the S means in Leon S Kennedy?
Sigma.
No, it means sky in Indian.
It means sigma.
Which map do you all want?
I don't want to go to school.
You want to go to school?
My wish is later.
You know what?
I hate the school, but sure, we can do it.
I want to go to school.
The girls pick my first.
You guys are not ready for what I'm putting on.
So it's like midwidge elementary school, right?
Yeah.
I'm going to come back to school.
That's awesome.
Awesome.
I don't know.
Are we focused?
Do you have any suggestions on what other two perks
I should put on because I don't remember anything?
OK.
Remember what?
I don't remember any.
OK, I'm just I'm just throwing stuff on.
OK, if you guys are ready, I'm ready it up.
If you're ready, I'm ready because I don't remember anything.
I only play only practice on Survivor yesterday on my own.
And I was like, OK, OK, I think I can
survive when I play with this one, the gang.
I was like, yeah, yeah, no, I'm not
going to be like a dead anchor.
Wait, should I remove all my perks?
Oh, wait, no, we're playing with perks.
No, no, everyone put your perks on.
I just had a brain fart.
Sorry.
Because I was like, oh, this wasn't happening with perks.
That's just because I'm stupid, they can't.
Me too, twinsies.
Oh my god.
Yes, sleigh.
Don't start.
Don't start working.
You've been playing too much dress, so we'll blow up.
Dress through a press.
You've been playing dress and press?
I've seen it everywhere.
Is it fun?
Yeah, I saw you're playing it a little bit.
Because I was like, because it's like so popular.
So I was like, OK, whatever.
I guess I will give it another try.
And then I just end up like disappointed.
And I'm like, OK, the shit's kind of ass, whatever.
But you're still playing it.
You got upset because I wouldn't play with you.
Well, no, it's because I had a stream.
So I was like, oh, maybe I can just invite you
to play dress through and press.
I'm having my second day dolothon, do you get you?
Yeah, but I was like, maybe you can just play
a dress through and press on stream with me
on your dolothon for a little bit.
I had a plan, I'm so sorry.
It's OK, I literally played it with me.
We ate.
We ate that wall away and slayed.
Oh my god, stop.
As the kids say.
This is in the school.
Oh, somebody else picked the YAMOKA residence.
So I'm putting the button in my mouth.
Wait, who picked the YAMOKA residence?
It isn't guaranteed when you do an offering.
Yeah, but I saw that somebody picked
YAMOKA residence, right?
Hey, what is it?
What is the Nicholas Cage drama?
Perk, do I go?
I think that's the one that.
I do not play as Nicholas Cage.
I see you.
OK, maybe I should have chased there.
I may have made a oopsie-woopsie, OK?
Oh, surprise.
No killing you guys.
Sorry, I fell off.
You fell off.
You didn't fall off.
You mean I was the best one?
And come in.
I see you breaking the gen.
Have you ever had haggis?
I'm sorry.
I have.
It's been this whole time.
Leon.
Have you ever had haggis?
Yes, I have.
It's actually not that bad, but I
don't know if you want to know what it's made of.
Or you'd rather know.
It's like made of like sheep.
Sheep lungs and intestines.
Yeah, it's kind of scary.
You don't think you can get away from me.
Leon, Leon, I'm hooked, Leon.
Oh, no.
Right, that's cheating.
Sorry, that's cheating.
I'm not going for you because you just got off the hook.
That's not fair.
That's cheating, Dylan.
That's called tunneling.
For those of you who don't play dead by delay,
they remove someone from the hook.
I'm not doing anything, bro.
I'm coming.
Oh, she fucking snagged me, bro.
I'm leaving you.
Sorry.
Don't be scared.
I'm coming.
Oh, we're chasing Mesma.
Should we chase the birthday girl?
That's so painful.
Shoot me, really.
Shoot me, shoot me.
What happened to it?
What happened to your happy birthday?
Someone's moaning.
I heard you because you were moaning.
I don't feel so good.
I don't know.
It's always Leon, too.
You don't move.
How did you do it?
I really don't want to bone anymore.
Thank you.
Come here.
Oh, my god.
This is a fucking mess.
I'm going to run.
I don't know anything I'm talking about.
Just accept it.
You're going to the void into the...
Is it the rift they call it?
I can't remember what they call it.
I'm coming for you.
Oh, hey.
Oh, someone ran over here.
Naughty, naughty.
When you run, I can see your footsteps.
No, you can't.
Boom.
You got a good aim.
No, really.
It's just really lucky.
Oh, there's another kid.
Okay.
Did I just see another cute girl
around this corner?
Did I just see another cute girl?
No, I didn't.
Okay.
You probably saw Leon Kennedy.
Which one?
I need to move.
Wait, I'm only alive one catcher.
Can we...
Can we all play as Leon as Kennedy?
I think they'll be fucking hilarious.
Okay, I'm not going for you
because you just go off the hook.
So who just took you off the hook?
Where are they?
Come here.
Where are you?
Are you hiding in the lockers?
Oh, I see Leon.
No?
Yes.
Damn it.
Who's popping?
Are you just popping his fire away?
Where are you?
Are you hiding in here in the bamboo?
Get out of the bamboo.
I can hear Misma moaning,
but I'm not tunneling Misma.
That's not nice.
Who is popping the gents?
I can literally see what you're doing on the map all the time.
I'm coming.
I'm sorry, I'm nervous.
I grabbed you.
Is that your second took?
Is this your second took?
Bro, I was like,
literally watching her dude.
I was like,
oh, well, I had stayed here.
Goodbye.
Is that your second took, Misma?
Yeah.
Okay, right.
I'll leave you.
I'm sorry.
It's just that the hunters makes my...
It makes me a little bit...
Yeah, exactly.
Thank you.
There isn't injured Leon around here,
so I'm trying to listen out for some moans.
I smell Leon.
Leon.
I need to help Leon.
Leon, I don't know where you are, Leon.
I'm at...
Hey, don't want me.
You're looking.
You're throwing it back.
Yeah, sure.
I'm literally down.
I'm so sorry.
I wasn't even looking.
I thought you were going to come
for the complete opposite direction,
so I was like,
oh, I wonder where she is.
I was the president.
Where are you, Leon?
Here, here.
How are you?
You're behind here.
I know one of you is here.
I don't know if it's Leon Twins,
but one of you is here.
I know you're here.
I'm going to walk away.
Someone's been working on this.
Your hips are so nice, Ada.
Don't talk to my wife like that.
She's my wife.
Fill me up.
I smell you.
Leon, touch me.
I see you.
I'm coming.
I'm touching you, Ada.
Yes.
Do you think a pallet is enough to stop me?
I am so cute.
You're even cuter when you're on the hook.
No, I don't want to.
I don't want to be on the hook.
You don't want to be a hooker?
No, I don't want to be on the hook.
I don't want to be a hooker.
They got a shit ton of money.
True or real?
You'll never get enough.
Please, ma'am.
Can I just have one generator?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, what the fuck?
I think we deserve one generator as a treat.
You want to save Leon?
I won't make it in time.
You're far away, you say?
Leon, you don't understand.
I'm very far away from you.
If you're far away, you must be over at this little generator here.
No, I'm really close, actually.
Are you close?
I'll make you close, all right.
Come here, Leon.
It's over.
You really think pallet stunning works with me?
This is scary.
It's over.
You know what?
What the fuck she did?
She made it through the window.
I can't hit past the window.
The killers can't hit past the window.
I swear, you have a really good aim.
Don't struggle.
I'm fucking dead.
Don't smell me, Zellie.
I got a birthday sweat.
Who just broke my totem?
Did someone just break my totem?
Leon, why did you do that?
Anger.
Not me.
I didn't do it in the bay.
Angers.
I got stunned.
I just got stunned.
I'm coming for you.
Leon, I mean danger, Leon.
Why do you sound like...
What, man?
Leon, I mean danger, Leon.
Where did you go?
I literally...
Where is everyone going playing bingo?
I'm here to tell you, ma'am.
I'm not into this.
I didn't even know where you went.
I wasn't...
I don't know what just happened.
Leon, I love it when you touch my body.
I mean, I love it when you touch my body, too, Ada.
You hate me.
Who's been doing this, January?
One of you are here.
I smell you.
Yes, I can tell.
I'm using my ancestors' hunting techniques.
I know one of you are here.
Are you in the slugger?
No.
Okay.
I'm gonna let you go.
As a courtesy, as an offering to the entity itself,
I'll give you a chance, but not for long.
I'm so bricked up right now.
Oh!
What was that soundboard?
I don't know.
Oh, my God.
I was gonna die, anyway.
I think you're all on your last took, unfortunately,
as much as I like to be a cheeky stall.
Oh, wait, hold on.
You should put me down.
Oh, you want me to put you down?
I'll put you down.
No, she's gonna kill me.
I'll put you down if you want it.
I can't believe this bro.
Why would you do this to me?
You asked for it.
Oh, miss, mom!
You're asking for it, too.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no, you're not on phase two, so I can't...
You're not on phase two, so I can't finish them for you.
Wait, why?
No, you're...
Yeah, you're struggling now.
Okay, that makes sense.
I'm coming.
I'm not good with skill checks, guys.
That's why I keep bombing the generator.
Where are you?
Missy, you don't have Nicholas Cage?
I'm being touched.
Why don't you have Nicholas Cage?
Are you both like Missy?
Missy, imagine the fucking biggest collab ever.
Leon as Kennedy and then Nicholas Cage.
Yeah, I was stinky, man.
You know exactly what was about to happen.
Don't start with me.
That's called tunneling.
I'm sure...
None of you just hate in lockers.
You guys are scared of what happens in the locker.
Okay, there was someone here.
Freakin' awesome.
You in the red dress, reveal yourself.
Even this locker?
Imagine if you were, though.
And I was about to walk away.
That would actually be really funny.
Okay.
You were here.
Don't think I didn't know your presence was around these parts.
But unfortunately, I can't find you, so...
I'm gonna go huntin' again.
What the hell?
I see Msma.
No, you don't.
Well...
I really don't want to tunnel you, but Msma,
I'll only keep fainting you.
I don't want to...
I don't want to ruin the vase for the birthday.
I'm giving preferential treatment before anyone says...
It's her birthday!
Who screamed?
Who's screaming?
Why are you...
Was that in-game or was that one of you?
Am I gone crazy?
Could've been me.
Sus.
This is sus.
What?
It's anything.
What's the...
How do you think it belongs to that?
Okay.
Killer time.
Ooh, are you working on this generator right here?
Oh my goodness!
Okay.
Are you working on this one, huh?
Do you think you have my permission to work on the generator?
Do not escape me.
I'm sorry, but you're dead as well.
A bluster?
A bluster!
Oh, we walked into each other!
Oh no!
Wait, where are you?
Oh, okay.
Happy birthday, Msma!
We love you!
Happy birthday to an axe to the face!
This is just what I wanted.
It's okay.
I want you to smile to me.
Happy birthday!
Okay.
Yeah, you can...
Expect it.
Yes, you'll be able to...
Expect what you're doing.
Pop that one.
Oh dear.
Somebody should play as the K-pop killer.
I think that would be funny.
Oh my god.
What was that?
He's my oppa.
Stop.
Damn!
Um...
Is that a hangover?
Oppa.
He's ghosted.
It's not funny.
It's on sale.
It's a killer that looks to the three same generators.
But, um...
Unfortunately, you guys are...
We've been unlucky and the last three gins are right next to each other.
So I know we use her around here.
Oh, I see you!
Leon!
I see you!
I have you.
Who are you flashing?
Who did you...
Did you flash me?
Did you just flash me?
Don't wait.
Do you have a perk where you don't have to make a skill check?
Why are you going in the basement?
No, I'm just getting really lucky.
Are you silly?
Where are you?
You're silly so good.
Don't go in the basement.
The basement is mine.
No.
Zellie's gonna die.
Just go find a basement.
I'm dying.
I'm gonna hide.
Two moments.
I'm just...
I'm coming for you.
She's going to catch you.
No, no.
She got this.
I'm looking for her.
Bro, I think it would be really funny if she just closes the attic.
You may get the hatch.
I don't know where you are.
Oh, not the attic.
I mean the hatch.
I never say that.
Okay.
Time to kill you.
Cause I found the hatch first.
I'm coming for you.
Don't be scared.
Come on.
You wanna let me win, don't you?
I'm not...
I'm not scared.
No, I'm not scared.
Are you pulling that door?
Oh, don't do that.
Naughty, naughty, naughty.
I'll let you guys have your moment.
That's the wrong gate.
I assure you.
You're going the wrong way.
You hear my heart beat.
Yes.
My gosh.
I can't find it.
What are you doing?
Don't touch that.
I didn't give you permission to touch that.
I'm teasing her.
I'm f**king teasing her.
I'm edging her.
Okay.
I'll let you go.
I messed up.
I messed up my aim.
Hold on.
Let me reload.
You better hurry up before I reload.
You better hurry.
You're so dead.
I'm not going to do it while you're pooling it.
Okay.
On the way out.
There you go.
Thank you.
Well played.
Well played, everyone.
That was fantastic.
You did amazing.
That was scary.
I won't be the killer again.
I'll let you guys play the game.
I was going to say,
if I got my times right,
I have to go into the mix.
No, that's fine.
That worked out perfectly.
Thank you so much for letting me be the killer
and having me,
and it was so nice to say hello and meet you all
for the first time.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Have an amazing time.
Bye.
Yeah, absolutely over.
I was having far too much fun killing them.
I'm sorry about that.
You like all my assets?
This is how excited for the stream I was.
Look, I'm all covered in blood.
I put blood tears on me.
I put blood over my chest.
I had my little hatchet.
I knew I was going to be playing the Hunter.
I knew.
I knew I was playing the Hunters.
Love your outfit.
Yeah, I'm gonna try and do this a bit more for streams. That was so lovely
Enjoyed that so much. You did amazing. I was having too much fun killing them
Is that what you said about the last family munkah? Was that scary in here?
Mmm
That was so good
Strony Yandere Hunter's RP. I hope I didn't kill the vibe so like too much because I was like actually sweating trying to win the game
I'm such a wee try hard
Um, but yes, uh, that was a fantastic club with the VNU girls. Oh my god
That's the first time I've like actually interacted with someone stream. I hope I didn't say anything to inappropriate
Are we gonna get more strony dead by daylight? Well speaking of dead by daylight clubs
My sin sister and I may or may not
Be hunting both the imps and the reeflings down at a later date. So no don't quit the game
There's currently a game mode called 2v8. Um, so
We're gonna hunt you guys down together
in stream
I believe one of them said I'm so break up right now. I'm looking forward to
Yeah, it goes away in four days. Yes. So sin and I are gonna do a collab very shortly very shortly because the game mode's gonna go away
um, I
Am you guys better be scared of strony after that performance. She's gonna carry me. Wait. Was that scary? Wait. Was that actually scary?
I was just having a lot of fun killing them
I think um
D gave that she was brave though
We can do custom matches
You want to do them right now? Can I do matches to get you guys in?
Maybe this maybe we'll pause fortnight another time and we could do dead by daylight if you want me to hunt you down
I wish I wasn't working right now
So how do I how would I get you guys in right now?
Play as
A custom game. Can I give a code?
I wasn't scary as the blood tears go down her cheek
Hold on. Let me let me put myself back in position. Maybe this will be the stream snipe for today and we'll play fortnight
Uh and an axe in her hand
Huh
We would have to add you
Can you do it without having friends?
I don't think so
match management
Yeah
Store shrines switch to survivor loadout character
Like split off of money. All right. You have to add a pagora. Oh wait. I didn't know we would have to add
I don't know sin. Are you streaming right now?
Do you just want to do two killers and get worked?
Or do you not have time right now?
Impromptu sin and the strongy collab on top of the other mysterious collab
Um, but I will update the description and the title of the stream afterwards just to say that who I collabed with because we
It didn't there was actually a few people like things got swapped around and I didn't want to like make a thumbnail in case they weren't in it
type thing
Uh, yeah, you have to use it in game friends list. Okay, right. No
Okay, if we if I can't just get in a game without adding you guys
What I'll do is I'm gonna make a throwaway dead by daylight steam account
like for that stuff
Cause I don't want people being like, oh
You know what I mean? Okay
A lot of good clips in the collab too. Wait, actually
I felt like I was being so boring. I'm like, oh
I'm glad they were having fun. No. Um, I hope I didn't bring it down or anything. I don't know if I can I really suck at freaking co-op
Anyway, mommy doesn't want to be friends with eyes
No, I don't want people being like, uh strongy had me as a friend, but didn't add me
Right what I'm going to suggest then my little
reeflings
Um, I am going to go offline for one
Hour and then we'll boot up boot it up mommy. Oh wait, hold on. Let me put a little love heart
Thank you so much for
that collab
That was so fun. Sorry if I got
scary
All the reeflings are saying I was terrifying. Oopsies. I just really like hunting things
And then I'll put loads of green hearts because that was very kind of mesmer to invite me
But yeah, one hour is chess going to be on. No, chess is I'm not doing chess
To today. Chester chess is today. When's the fortnight fennel pen?
Or I tell you what
I could actually just redirect into the fortnight and if you give me literally five minutes
I'm like a cup of tea and then we'll do no you were cute scary. Okay. Good. Good. Good. Good. I'm gonna just
We'll serve a woman
Okay, right hear me out. Hear me out reeflings. I'm gonna redirect you into the fortnight
metal pen
I'll just shit
I'm a
And if you give me five minutes, I will make a
cup of honey tea
And then we'll you can strange snipe me
But you have to give me five minutes because the kettle takes three minutes to boil
And then I'll pour the tea the boiling water into the cup
With a little bit of honey
And some milk. I can't I can't I can't I'm crazy. Um, right
Don't forget to add the reefling ink too. Um, I am going to redirect into my fortnight stream
Okay, I know it says this an hour away or maybe two hours depending on how I timed it says it's an hour away. Okay
Um, I am going to redirect if you give me five minutes. I'm a tinkle
And I'm uh get a cup of tea and then we can play fortnight together
Fortnight battle pass. I just shite oot my arse
And we don't say that we don't say that shite like that in the sentence. Um, just so you know, okay
Yeah, I'm gonna end broadcast. Give me five minutes. You'll be redirected into the fortnight and then we can all play fortnight
Battle pass. Okay. Love you reeflings. I'll see you on the other side. Um
I need to take off all the blood. I just realized I need to take the blood off me